for more on the crisis at our southern
border joining us now fox news
contributor and former ice director
under president trump tom holman tom you
just heard from bill molesion's report
about this uh outstanding year-end ice
report still not in and you heard from
that former ice agent victor avila
saying that the reason why they won't
release it is because they fundamentally
abolished ice your thoughts
well first of all
i've said for weeks they're not released
releasing the report for two reasons
number one they're trying to figure out
how to spin the numbers that report's
been done since the middle of october i
know cause we did that report the 12
years i was in headquarters i know that
report is done by mid-october so i have
the numbers that report sitting at the
white house the domestic policy council
they're trying to figure out how to spin
it and i also think they're not going to
release it because they know on february
1st in a little over a week i tom holman
is going to be testifying in in court in
texas in the bite administration lawsuit
on how they abolish the ice mission
and that report would be exhibit a
everything i've said in the past year is
true isis mission has pretty much been
abolished you're going to see less than
60 000 removals which is a 70 decline
from last year an 80 decline from
trump's uh last year and as far as the
arrest the arrest is going to be less
than 60 000
and there's 5 000 agents which means
if you do the math that means every
agent in ice made an arrest every three
months made one arrest every three
months so it's it's devastating it's
going to be it could be the lowest
number in the history of this agency and
it's going to improve what we've been
saying griff that this administration
has abolished the uh mission of ice
tom there was a speech by dhs secretary
marcus this week to the conference of
mayors here in washington i happened to
tune in because i was curious to see
what he said this didn't get much
attention in the media or anywhere
really that i saw listen to a little bit
of what he had to say
unlawful presence in the united states
will alone
not be a basis for an immigration
enforcement action but rather
we will allocate
our efforts we will allocate our
resources on those individuals who
present
a current public safety threat
a threat to national security
or a threat to our border security
tom it sounds like he's saying it's okay
to illegally cross our border so long as
you're a good person and you don't
commit any serious crimes but what
message does that send south of the
border
it doesn't mess with the whole world
it's okay to enter his country illegally
and in the secretary he's he he can't
rewrite the law
when you enter the country illegally it
is a crime spelled out in title eight
united states code 1325. so he's telling
sworn officers who supposed to enforce
immigration law that you can't arrest
them by being here illegally and that's
just going to be another mag that bring
more people here and i'll tell you
something else he says they want to
concentrate and focus on the criminals i
guarantee you when this report gets
released the number of criminals
arrested and deported are going to be
down at least 50 percent i know that i
talk to ice every day their hands are
tied he is not the secretary of homeland
security he's the secretary of homeland
insecurity this country is less safe
under his leadership than president
biden he needs to be impeached for that
very statement he made telling foreign
officers ignore the law ignore the oaks
you took this is an open borders and we
can't stop it
tom they are also not releasing
dhs will release the december
apprehension numbers we found in a court
filing it's about 178 000 according to
their filing if you look just at the
first three months october november and
december the traditionally slowest
months on the border last year's numbers
pale in comparison to what we're seeing
this year alone in the first three
months more than 500 000 apprehensions
what are we headed for
look the numbers will continue to rise
because there's no consequence there's
no deterrence they know they can cross
illegally they know they'll be released
and not detained they even if they get
an order even even if they show up in
court which most don't and the judge
orders them removed you just heard the
secretary ice can't execute the order so
why shut down the immigration courts why
issue
why you order an alien you must leave
the country
when ice can't go arrest them and kick
them out of the country the secretary
just said being in the country illegally
is not enough to make an arrest so why
are we sending all these people to
immigration court have a federal judge
make the decision to remove them but we
can't remove them
it's disgusting
i've said it many times under president
trump president trump was a game changer
he gave us the most secure border i've
seen in my entire career illegal
immigration down 83 percent this
president is the first president history
of my life in history this nation that
came into office and intentionally and
purposely unsecured the border which has
caused death which has caused fentanyl
to cause a hundred thousand deaths which
is called uh uh known as suspected
terrorists across the border yeah border
patrol's arrest is 16 there's a half a
million got aways yeah how many of us
gotta waste our known suspected
terrorists griff it's unbelievable
fentanyl up 134 percent tom homan thank
you for your insight we look forward to
following your testimony as well as we
wait for this ice report thank you sir